next up we have alejandro alex james
he's the CTO and chief scientist at x
ezo they focus on big data for
predictive analytics in health care to
tackle disease at a worldwide scale they
use an artificial intelligence to
collect and analyze data to track to
track and predict disease in ways that
have never been done before prior to
joining them Alex was CTO at AI cure and
prior to that he was the director of
research and video products at Yahoo
where he led research and contributions
to Yahoo's video products managing
scientists in New York City sunnyvale
bangalore and barcelona welcome thanks
for joining us thank you so thanks for
the invitation are very happy to be here
and thanks everyone for coming back from
the break I know it's very enticing to
stay and have more coffee and chat so
I'm fairly new to health care i've been
doing health care for a little more than
a year now and so my background is more
technical like I spent a number of years
at Yahoo and other large companies like
fuji xerox and telephony kind so on and
so forth so I have a kind of different
perspective on health care that's part
of what i want to share with you and i
want to talk about you know how i think
health care will change in the next few
years and and specifically what we're
doing it s SEO to that regard so health
care and this is pretty interesting if
you think about it you know it's it's
really based on data and models so in
many ways it's kind of the
quintessential example of machine
learning right you go to a doctor and in
a typical visit you know they collect
data and then they match your data to a
mental model that they have right they
make a diagnosis and then there's action
and so it's pretty much a classification
problem and I'm not trying to downgrade
the medical profession because a big
part of that is a human touch and the
human interaction
that's really really really important at
the same time you know it's it's pretty
obvious that the health care system in
most countries is completely broken
there's just overwhelming demand not
enough supply you know doctors are
overwhelmed you know they see you and
they want to get you out of there as
quickly as possible it's really really
hard for them and then you have you know
insurance companies on one side
pharmaceutical company it's a very very
complex systems system and at the end of
the day it's really if you look at the
problem from this point of view it's a
machine learning problem and you know
what doctors do for the most part in
their training over many many years is
collect data and refine those models
right that's that's essentially a big
part of the medical profession and so I
have this video which I like a lot on
and and I'm and I'm just you know
wondering if this relates in any in any
way to data in healthcare let's see so
and you know it's a funny video and you
know I use it in other contexts but I
think in healthcare one of the
challenges and I'll talk about this a
little bit more later is that
information technology and computers are
not necessarily seen as a as an
essential part of the ecosystem you know
i would say in most cases there's view
as a cost their cost center not at not a
place for opportunity in to improve so
that's that's one of the challenges in
spite of that if we think about this
model that I talked about earlier how
much data does a doctor see in there
like they're in their lifetime right
even the most successful physician how
many people do they see a year it's
really really a tiny amount right in
comparison to you know a population of a
single hospital or a city or the number
of employees of a large company right if
we look at the data and aggregate how
whether it's really really significant
right so in terms of that per year that
can be prevented it's about 440,000
about 80,000 are due to the wrong
diagnosis the third leading cause of
death in the u.s. is medical error one
in ten diagnosis or wrong around 30 new
diseases since 1980 most of the data is
unstructured and the market is of course
gigantic right and there are more facts
you know and I can't even pronounce
those words you know that the amount of
data is just huge huge huge but if we
look at the context beyond just
healthcare we need to really think about
what affects health care right or health
so it's not just health care data that's
relevant there's a lot more data that is
really important so who and I Bible who
I mean the World Health Organization has
listed what they call determinants of
health and so they have them three broad
categories social and economic
environment physical environment and the
purse the person's individual
characteristics and and behaviors right
so it seems pretty obvious that each of
our health depends on all of these
external variables in spite of that when
we think about it most of that is not
really taken into account right we go to
doctor and they you know they measure
certain things and they make a diagnosis
but all this data that we're collecting
on a daily basis is not really being
used so just to go down that list in a
little bit more of detail you know what
are the determinants swording to the
world health organization that that
impact health income and social status
it's pretty obvious higher income and
social status and implies better health
education again lower levels of
education are linked with poor health
physical environment safe water clean
air workplaces houses communities all of
these leads to differences in health
employment and working conditions have a
huge impact we spend a lot of time at
work
right and so if we keep going down that
list social support networks community
you know whether you have friends or
family you know this really impacts your
health matches your mental health but
your physical health culture and
traditions have have a big impact the
community itself and then of course
personal behavior which is obviously
influenced by all of the above right you
know there are a lot of initiatives and
apps and startups doing a lot of
attempting to do behavioral change and a
lot of it is based on community right
for quitting smoking and some other
applications and then of course access
to health services has a tremendous
impact on on your health not only in
terms of prevention but in terms of
actual treatment now where is the
evidence for this long list of things so
the World Health Organization has worked
on trying to collect some of this
evidence and try to figure out whether
there is real evidence to support these
claims or not and and there's enough
information to point us in that
direction and say yes you know there's
definitely a big impact you know of
Transportation on health and you know
when I started reading about this well
obviously you know if the roads are not
good and the rules are not followed
there are more accidents so that's a
pretty basic example of where
transportation itself has an impact on
your health if you're commuting two
hours a day you know and you're driving
and heavy traffic that clearly has an
impact on your mental health the food
that we eat has a big impact which is
why certain diseases happen in certain
regions and that in other regions or
there's more incidents in one regions in
other regions this is again linked to
social economic status right if you eat
a lot of fast food and I don't know how
many of you saw that we actually never
saw it but the guy who
McDonald's for I don't know how long
eventually ended up getting sick I think
right so what you eat depends a lot on
the resources you have around you if you
live in a poor neighborhood where you
end up a lot of eating a lot of fast
food because cheapest option then that's
going to help affect your health and it
might not do it you know this week or
next week or next year but it will do it
in the next five or ten years there was
an interesting article I can remember
where it was but it was about the cost
of inexpensive food and arguing you know
you might be pay more for a vegetarian
meal or an organic salad or whatever but
at the end of the day longer term maybe
you're saving money rights of food and
agriculture housing waste energy
industry urbanization water radiation
nutrition and health so they listed this
in order of where they found the most
evidence and so I that's why I think the
first one is the easiest one right in
places where the people don't follow the
rules and they drive like maniacs
they're more accidents right nutrition
and health is a lot harder to track in
its longer-term right whereas with an
accident you immediately can see the the
impact now in addition to all of that
one thing that's really unique about the
time we're in now is that the world is
so connected and I don't mean just
Facebook connected right most of us flew
here or took the train from different
locations right and if you look at the
amount of travel it's really
mind-boggling you know how people are
moving people and goods it's incredible
and not just immigration which is what
travel right and we saw an earlier talk
today about transportation when we look
at any product we have you know it comes
from many different places so
understanding you know what were you
even what we're eating is becoming
really difficult because the components
come from everywhere right but this has
an impact
that is significant on health and it has
an impact on the environment as well I
travel alone that's just one of the
areas so if we look at fuel emissions
this is a graph that I found again
significant shift so as the environment
changes we can expect Raider changes in
in health due to that so what we're
focusing on is environmental Public
Health right and here's an overview of
sort of public health so we have
behavioral science by statistics
Environmental Health semiology health
services administration so the focus is
really on the environment and and that's
a pretty broad topic because it really
includes people lifestyle community the
local economy the natural environment
and the built environment you know at
the end of the day you know we talk
about the environment it's not just the
trees and the water and whether it rains
or not but it's you know the the actual
streets we live on what we eat and and
and so on and so forth so when we look
at the possibilities in the again in the
context of that data there's a huge
amount of data and healthcare itself
that's not being exploited and there's a
huge amount of data that's external to
healthcare that can give us insights on
how our health is its impacted and then
we have the tech stack that's been used
very extensively by companies like Yahoo
where I worked for a number of years and
other web companies and many of the
companies that are here and at the same
time we're not really using that yet you
know there's it's it the the field is
just beginning right and so what are the
possibilities obviously prediction
management efficiency and an axis so
I'll get into a few more details the
market is is of course huge and you know
you can see all kinds of numbers on what
the market is but the reality is health
care is a big expense in pretty much
every every single country so the basic
idea is to
make all of these different diverse data
sources use a combination of machine
learning algorithms not just deep
learning but all kinds of algorithms
with knowledge bases to improve health
care multiple stages so one is obviously
detection and classification looking at
insights on disease progression so if
you know that somebody comes from a
lives in an area where certain things
happening from an environmental point of
view and there are higher risk of x and
y then for example if you're an
insurance company you might create
incentives for those individuals to get
tested on certain things earlier rather
than later right but in order to do that
you need to understand those
correlations between between the
environment and in health try adding as
well population health management better
health outcomes so you know when I d I
started with an example of somebody
going to a doctor to you know just for a
regular checkup imagine if you came to
the doctor and you know the way that it
happens now is you know the doctor will
ask you a few questions they'll take
your temperature whatever right so it's
a few data points a few features you
think of a machine learning model and
then there's a diagnosis if that
diagnosis if that data collection were
compared to the doctor visits if it's a
200,000 people your age that have
exactly the same symptoms that have
maybe the same DNA makeup decision could
be made in an instant right the doctors
role in that particular case if there's
even a need to see a doctor and I'm not
saying that technology would replace
doctors would then shift to not the
ninety-five percent of the cases that
are easy where we can use computation to
make the diagnosis but maybe to that
five percent
that is more too much more complex and
more difficult than where there's
something is not right and maybe the
doctor can see it because they have a
lot of experience and this would
completely shift the healthcare model so
that doctors can focus on the on the
more important and more difficult cases
and and make the processes help more
efficient more cost-effective bringing
better health outcomes and in savings
for everyone you know government's
insurance companies and individuals
obviously so when you go into the
details clearly you know there's a huge
amount of data and it's it's really
spread out all over the place and this
is very complex graph and I don't expect
anyone to actually you know go through
all of the details but there are so many
different sources of data so there's
structured data unstructured data
there's data that you know is is I guess
the EHR there's data about procedures
there's data about your you know entire
medical history that may not be in the
HR because you've been you've moved
countries where you switch from one
place to another vaccines data you know
it's it's a lot of it is really messy
it's complex it's it's fairly
heterogeneous data and then sort of you
know aside from the healthcare data we
have things like credit card purchases
mobility behavior again things like
commuting time even and you know there's
been some research in the last few years
looking at social media and what people
post on social media as indicators for
health and as possible predictors for
health issues and I think that's an area
where you know there's a lot of work to
be done and the key challenge there is
really trying to integrate all of these
different kinds different data sources
into a single model or in
way that we can leverage the
opportunities afforded by by all of them
as they're integrated so the basic idea
is you know and I'm going to make an
analogy sort of with the web ecosystem
and the app ecosystem use apps and when
you use apps you use the web you get a
lot of services for free and you do this
in exchange for your data right so one
possibility you know in the healthcare
space is that you're not going to get
free health care but by giving your data
that data will be used in aggregate with
the data of many other patients and so
you would be able to leverage the models
that are built from data aggregated from
thousands or millions of patients so if
you think about it it's it's it's a it's
a doable model and the challenge and
I'll talk a little bit more about that
later it's of course there's a lot of
regulation there are privacy issues
there are complications but the data is
there and there are large payer systems
large hospital systems that have that
kind of data and there are ways to
anonymize that and aggregate it and so
that's that's what we're aiming for so
the basic idea is you collect the data
you have models that are being
constantly improved and updated based on
on additional additional data is coming
in so you're as the patient contribute
we also benefiting from everybody else
who've seen the doctor and so the key
there is of course privacy insecurity so
the basic idea is to use machine
learning applied interaction disease
prediction in population risk in and
I'll go into some more specific example
so the opportunities really at three
levels one is at the hospital level
where when I say hospital I mean you
know it could be individual doctor to go
to the doctor and and there are tools
that aid in the diagnosis right based on
the symptoms that you have and all the
data aggregated from many other patients
at the health system level you want to
see trends on on on the population in
the environment
it and then of the government level you
know it's pretty clear that you want to
understand these correlations between
environmental variables and disease you
can take action whether it's by public
campaigns to advertise certain behaviors
and help people watch their hands which
we've seen or you know do things like
take certain medications for prevention
of HIV or you know what what whatever
that is so those are the sort of three
levels that were working with anyway I
see the the big opportunities for big
data in healthcare so just as an example
of what this might look like you know if
you look at breast cancer one in eight
women in the US develop it over the
course of their lives it's the second
most frequent cause of death and the
incidence rates really vary regionally
and so that's that's pretty interesting
like why why is that you know what what
are the factors that could possibly lead
people in some countries to have higher
incidence of breast cancer than in other
countries so to do this kind of analysis
what we're doing is we're again looking
at very different types of data that's
in silos and aggregating it and doing a
lot of exploratory analysis and applying
machine learning techniques to identify
what are those factors that are first of
all you know there's some that we can
classify immediately as being biological
behavioral social or physical but then
we want to determine the strength you
know are they strong modest or weak and
one really really critical issue which
you know some of these previous speakers
have talked about is the data quality
right we need to look at all the data
and really dig deep in finding out what
what the quality is and how how to
overcome the data quality issues
challenges and I'm close to the end so
I've talked about them a little bit but
you know in general
data silos data duplication
unidirectional information and the lack
of strategic insights so you know the
data is really divided into all of these
different groups we have you know data
from pharmaceutical companies clinical
data you have claimed Zeta and then
patient behavior I think the future is
optimistic and one of the reasons is
that unfortunately the health care
system is broken and so there's no way
out but something needs to be done and
and for that reason things that we're
moving to an outcome space model and so
that's placing a lot of pressure on
doctors and hospitals to be more
effective and more efficient at the same
time you know there's this whole startup
ecosystem on wellness which i think is
really interesting because it can at
least on the last bucket there on
patient behavior can maybe contribute
and then there's all the data that's
being collected that was not available
in the past now one of the challenges
that I think we still have and I'll pay
another funny video to wake people up is
as I said before
computers are still annoying
and they're extremely frustrating you
know and I think when you talk to
doctors I think you get the point when
you talk to doctors I think they all
want to embrace technology but part of
problem is a lot of the tech that has
gone into healthcare it's really not the
most usable not the most friendly
doesn't have the best design you know
and so we need to do a lot of work to
change that and I think the way we we
can do that is by taking an approach
that is human centered and I've been
talking about this for many years you
know before I join you out when I kept
talking about it well i was at yahoo but
the basic idea is you know the user is
at the center and you have three
different entry points for innovation
one is data the other ones hypotheses
and the other ones design it all has to
be done within a context and so you only
innovate if you cycle through these and
so you look at the data but then you
need to revisit your hypotheses
understand the design of the system or
the interface or whatever the data where
the data is coming from and then the
more you do this the more the deeper you
go and the closer you get to the user so
unless you do you cycle through this
many many times that's that's that's a
big part of being a data scientist and
doing big data analysis unless you do
that you don't innovate and you don't
get to that to that point so at the end
of the day you know it's really an
intersection of user experience data
analysis human aspects with machine land
learning at the intersection right and
what better place in healthcare to do
this you know there's it's a human
activity right it's really really
critical but we need to understand the
experience not only of the doctors using
the technology but also of the patients
analyze the data and understand all the
human aspects which I talked about
before socioeconomic status and so on
and so forth so I'm going to close with
two or three more slide so I'm I you
know I talk about five dimensions for
big data one is designed because all the
data you get
on the design of your interface or
whatever it is right so changing the
design will change the data and vice
versa algorithmic you can change the
algorithm the diagnosis or
recommendation algorithm can give you
insights on the population social
cultural insights on the population
again and then personal insights right
for each individual patient or each
individual doctor so in order to do this
one of the things that I do in most of
my work is combined qualitative and
quantitative methods so informal
interviews focus groups surveys
crowdsource saying user evaluations a be
testing so this is really really
critical in the sort of data science
practice so the key points you know even
though I've talked so much about data I
think it's less about the eight and it's
more about behavior and understanding
those environmental variables you know
what what in the behavior of people
affects their health and how can we
change that interaction and designer key
elements and you know the funny videos
with the computer being bitten up and
stuff speak to that you know if we don't
build systems that are very usable by
doctors and patients will never succeed
and I think we're at the point where we
can actually do that and so in order to
do all of this it's key to segment
experiment iterate and innovate within a
specific context so data science must be
strategic tap down exploratory bottom-up
have the right metrics a be testing is
really critical strong human and
interdisciplinary focus and what is the
next frontier and this is just too close
I think small data so everyone's talking
about big data but at the end of the day
you know if we think of ourselves as the
individuals benefit from all of this
it's the things we do that that matter
the most and looking at the details is
really really critical thank
you